Apple's new 2020 MacBook Air has been
out for about three weeks now and we
initially thought that people looking to
buy a base MacBook Pro should just buy
the MacBook Air instead but we couldn't
be more wrong we were initially very
excited about how great this MacBook Air
could be for three main reasons the drop
in price down to a thousand dollars the
switch to the excellent magic keyboard
and the $100 quad core i5 CPU upgrade
which also included graphics that were
faster than any 13-inch MacBook Pro this
all sounded great and we thought it
would be a better value than the base
macbook pro but after we started doing
deeper testing we discovered a massive
flaw which we'll get into in a minute in
this video we're gonna give you three
reasons why people who want a powerful
quad core macbook should just wait for
the 20/20 macbook pro instead of buying
a current MacBook Air or a pro four
reason number one there have been rumors
coming out that actually point to the
new MacBook Pro coming much sooner than
expected
recently the well-known analyst mingsha
quo predicted the release of a refreshed
MacBook Pro in quarter 2 of 2020 which
could be anywhere from April to June yet
at the same time he also announced the
release of a 14 point one inch MacBook
Pro alongside a refreshed 16 inch
macbook pro both with mini LED displays
with this points to is the possibility
that there will be two separate releases
of the smaller MacBook Pro this year
according to Apple leaker John Prosser
the refreshed 13-inch Pro codenamed J 2
2 3 is actually coming sometime this
month in May as long as everything goes
well and then he also went on to say
that it'll be a refresh to the 13-inch
MacBook Pro separate from the also
expected 14 inch display upgrade so his
info matches up to mingsha quotes now I
personally had a hard time believing
that Apple could have released a new
MacBook Pro during this coronavirus
crisis but Apple proved us wrong last
month by successfully releasing the new
iPad pro and MacBook Air and is also
pretty encouraging that the lock downs
in China are finally being lifted
meaning that Apple device production
should hopefully be going back to norm
soon along with that stock analyst Jim
Cramer mentioned that Apple stocks
suddenly seems attractive
now that China is coming back online so
based on this we could very well see a
refreshed 13-inch MacBook Pro this month
now don't take my word for it but it
could happen the next two reasons we'll
explain why you shouldn't buy one of the
quad-core MacBook Air or MacBook Pro
models right now reason number two is
that the new quad core i5 MacBook Air is
just not a good option for anyone who
really cares about performance because
of its massive flaw the fact that the
fan is still not connected to the CPUs
heatsink we didn't expect this to be too
much of an issue at first since the new
10th Gen Intel CPU should be much more
efficient but after doing deeper testing
we discovered that the CPU quickly
reached up to a hundred degrees Celsius
not only while doing things like gaming
or video editing but also browsing the
web using Chrome and watching 4k 60fps
YouTube videos so we actually
recommended people with the quad-core
model to turn off turbo boost
in order to keep the CPU cool while
doing regular tasks and for video
editing the overheating was so bad that
even though the MacBook Air scored great
in both the CPU and metal benchmarks it
ended up being twice as slow as the base
macbook pro while exporting a 4k youtube
video so in our final review of the
20/20 MacBook Air we actually went back
to recommending the base dual-core model
for regular computing tasks so for
people who need a basic MacBook for
things like browsing the web using
common apps or watching Netflix
the base MacBook Air is absolutely the
best value macbook we've seen in years
and that's because you're getting double
the storage than before for $100 less
than before as well as getting the new
much more reliable magic keyboard but
for those who want great performance
let's get into the third reason why you
should wait the current 13-inch MacBook
Pro is really missing out on some great
features that we already know are coming
to the 2020 model and we know this for
sure because if the MacBook Air got
these new features then the upcoming
but pro will 100% get them as well the
most important one is the fact that it
packs the old butterfly keyboard which
people have complained about for years
because of an issue where random Keys
would simply stop working both the 16
inch MacBook Pro and the air are already
using the new magic keyboard and we
think it's the best keyboard they've
ever created due to having a combination
of excellent key travel great
reliability in the tactile feel of the
butterfly key switches all into one
keyboard the next feature the current
MacBook Pro is missing is the new 10th
gen processor since the MacBook Air just
got one the current 13-inch Pro is
actually stuck using an old 8th gen chip
so the switch to attention processor is
going to improve performance and
efficiency as well and since the fan is
actually connected to the heatsink we
should see better thermal performance
than last year and not only that but the
new 10th gen chip will also pack the new
much faster integrated graphics just
like the g7 graphics in the air which
will help for things like video editing
in a huge surprise to everyone was that
the RAM speed in the new MacBook Air
went up to 3000 733 megahertz that's 75%
faster than the RAM in the current
13-inch Pro and finally a huge downside
of the current 13-inch MacBook Pro is
the very low 128 gigs of storage on the
base model we've personally been
recommending buyers to upgrade to at
least 256 gigs if they want a good
experience and since we know that the
base model MacBook Air now comes with
256 gigs then every future macbook pro
should come with at least this much as
well so those are the main reasons why
people looking to buy a well performing
quad-core MacBook should just wait until
the 20 2013 inch MacBook Pro comes out
but there's also the dilemma of why
Apple would release both a 13-inch
refresh and a 14 inch MacBook Pro within
a few months of each other well I
believe that if Apple does end up doing
this then the 14 inch mini LED MacBook
Pro will almost certainly replace the
higher-end
$1,800.00 model at least
first so for those who don't see
themselves paying $1,800 for a MacBook
Pro there's really no point in waiting
around for it for you the 13-inch
MacBook Pro refresh which could come
this month will be great because it'll
get the 10th gen and the new magic
keyboard so hopefully this video helped
you guys out and if it did its have to
like button below and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one check out our MacBook Air
review right over there and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]